[Musique]
de luxe et un groupe qui existe depuis
2007 c'est 5 moustachu kg à la batterie
et beatmaking callas à la base qui sont
en retrait quand il avait 6 ans donc
c'est vraiment un groupe de potes avant
d'être un groupe de musique ils ont
rencontré piètre à la guitare un peu au
collège the poor s ouvrit le
percussionniste et le vidéaste au lycée
et pépé le saxophoniste multi
instrumentiste super un critique un peu
à cette période là aussi et le lire je
les ai rejoints en 2010 quand ils y
jouent et dans les provinces
[Musique]
ont messi fait qu'on a des goûts super
différents en fait été et qu'on se prive
de rien
jean démence entre morceaux très
différente de l'un à l'autre mais je
dirais qu'on fait de la musique de scène
les paroles c'est un peu hommage à notre
histoire et est à nous d mon anneau d
mookie qui font que on a la rage de
toujours s'acharner d'aller toujours
plus loin tous les jours ils poussent et
de projets toujours plus loin et c'est
cette même chronique parfois kate and is
et donne envie de se cacher quoi
[Musique]
il ya des parties acoustique du bon
vieux de l'uff qui cartonne et qui fait
danser qui fait djembé il ya des moments
beaucoup plus intimiste quand vous
demande de ne pas de gêne t et de
claquer des doigts plutôt que de de
clapet des mains on essaie de de
toujours faire ce qu'on a toujours adoré
faire plan d'interaction avec le public
[Musique]